on peut diriger la ville de montréal
sourire
mais n'ont qu'à gagner son pain gris
c'est à l'aube où le vin à montréal on
va retrouver tout de suite la mairesse
réélu valérie plantes bonsoir madame
plante ça madame drolet madame plante on
vous retrouve au dans quel état d'esprit
aujourd'hui le vous êtes fatigué vous
êtes heureuse la batterie est un peu
plus faible pierre êtes comment
bah écoutez j'ai envie de vous dire
tellement fier tellement heureuse parce
que cette victoire le allait éclater en
cette majorité que la population nous
donne dans plein de et les
arrondissements qu'on va continuer à
mettre de l'avant et également le sport
le résultat pour pour moi et c'est
évident que ça me touche énormément
parce que non seulement j'ai été la
mairesse pendant les quatre dernières
années mais j'ai aussi traversé la
pandémie avec les montréalais et
montréalaises donc j'avoue que ça me
touche puis je prends à nouveau ce
mandat avec beaucoup d'humilité c'est
une grande responsabilité opel à
laquelle je veux faire honneur avec un
gain de plus aujourd'hui dans côte des
neiges notre dame il s'est passé quelque
chose vraiment alors votre candidate qui
a été élu là c'est madame gracia kazuki
katawal qui affrontait lionel perez qui
lui était quand même le chef du parti
d'opposition il a perdu l'an non
seulement monsieur coderre a perdu non
plus lui qui était chef de l'opposition
a perdu
quelle lecture vous faites de ça
je pense qu'elle est mariée à l'un et
morel ont clairement dit 'oui' à tous
les candidats confondues que la notion
même de prendre soin de la vie de
quartier de la mettre en valeur de se
souhaiter de la mixité économique
culturelle et générationnelle
dia le logement via le transport via les
services à la population via la
transition écologique c'est important
pour eux et nous on a toujours est un
parti qui mettait les citoyens et la vie
de quartier à l'avant plan comme étant
pas quelque chose de deux petits uddin
intéressant bédié comme étant une valeur
fondamentale va fondamentales pendant
qu'il fait rayonner bon
le problème de son
on vous entend bien là c'est juste que
c'est un guichet est ce que vous avez
fait que denis coderre a cherché à vous
contacter le vais vous parler depuis
hier
alors voilà hier lorsque j'ai contacté
ce qu'avec monsieur aunès finalement
j'ai laissé un message à denis et puis
on patine ouvert je lui ai envoyé un
petit texto samatan disant je tremblais
un beau message appelle moi et
finalement été il ya quelques minutes là
j'ai reçu une réponse est finalement par
texto et puis voilà l'important c'est
que à partir de ce moment la population
a parlé cet exercice démocratique a eu
lui et puis on avance qu'est ce que vous
dit dans son texto
comme il me souhaite bonne chance
qu'il va avoir plusieurs des filles pour
montréal au cours des prochaines années
et qu'il souhaite vraiment que tous les
partis tous les élus travaillent
ensemble ce que je souhaite également
ardemment parce que oui il ya des défis
pour prendre également de belles
solutions mais j'ai envie de monsieur
coderre reste ou pas en politique
municipale
oui en effet vous avez raison je ne sais
pas si on n'a pas parlé de ça
là vous avez une majorité très clair au
conseil par les moines qu'est ce que ça
vous donne comme avantage quelle
latitude se voudrait écouter dans notre
premier mandat on avait déjà une
majorité et on a vu ce que ça nous a
permis de faire de maître des règlements
pour protéger l'habitation de protéger
un grand parc de d'acheter des terrains
dans l'ouest on a vraiment pu mettre le
pied sur l'accélérateur sur des projets
importants
alors c'est sûr que pour nous ça nous
donne ce levier là pour pour les
prochaines années est justement question
de trans en écologie qu'il faut faire de
grands changements
bien sûr je le fais avec l'ensemble des
élus mais ça nous donne les coudées
franches et évidemment le rapport de
force que l'on peut avoir avec québec à
ottawa il est également très présent
dans mon résultat personnel à titre de
mairesse 52% le sait c'est quand même
assez c'est important et aussi d'avoir
cette majorité là c'est que ça nous
permet d'avoir une conversation encore
plus
trash et directe avec d autres pas les
gouvernements êtes-vous devenu une
personnalité incontournable comme le
étaient régis labeaume par exemple on
savait il fallait avoir de monsieur
labeaume de son bas quand on était en
politique peu importe appelé les
gouvernements est ce que c'est en train
de devenir la même chose avec montréal
et madame plantes mais je pense que il
ya les personnalités les gens bien sûr
qui incarne le rôle de ma mère s mais
aussi quelle ville on représente donc
dans le cas de régis de par son
expérience va aussi étant la capitale et
dans mon père étant la métropole c'est
un incontournable on est un
incontournable nécessairement mais c'est
évident que cette ce deuxième mandat
forte de l'expérience
d'apprentissage parce que j'ai appris
vraiment beaucoup de choses
nécessairement vont très bien me servir
au cours des prochains mois vous
couronne maintenant les colonnes à
montréal n'aurait su est de nouveau
maire aussi une génération nouvelle
gamme mais vous partager plusieurs
priorités l'environnement la transition
écologique que les transports en commun
l'habitation au logement ça va vous
donner quand même une force de frappe
dans le discours l'a d'abord des alliés
comme ça je vous avais représentait plus
que montréal
absolument mois évidemment comme maire
je suis déjà la présidente de la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal et
j'ai travaillé très fort pour amener les
enjeux psychologiques et d'habitation à
l'avant plan mais c'est évident que des
nouveaux maires et mairesses qui ont
cette préoccupation-là histoire et quand
on regarde en fait des belles des belles
choses sont passées pendant cette
campagne électorale la à la grandeur du
québec et des agendas vraiment connecté
à la 35 aux logiques et l'habitation
comme on n'a jamais vu avant moi pour
moi ça c'est porteur d'avenir ça veut
dire que tout le monde pour 5 petites
municipalités où une grande on se
préoccupe aussi ce que nos citoyens nous
demande mais évidemment dans mon rôle de
métropole et comme hub mais reste de
montréal locomotive économique et
culturel de la province évidemment j'ai
bien l'intention de continuer à jouer
son rôle de leader ou partager des
outils d apprentissage faire avancer des
grandes ou petites sociétés on en
prendra quand félicitations et puis ces
nouveaux moments de bonheur mais voilà
merci beaucoup merci à vous pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit